do you look at the cost of raising a
child is completely and utterly bonkers
we do have a mother on the panel so
we're going to find out firsthand CNN
calculated the average cost of raising a
child to the age of 18 throughout the
country so let's take a look okay so
what you're seeing here that on the
bottom you see in the years of age and a
one-year-old costs about looks around
thirteen thousand bucks and that you get
around there for the first seven or
eight years and then around ten it
starts jumping and then gets
precipitously higher so that by 18
you've spent around two hundred and
forty five thousand dollars this
includes childcare and education
healthcare food housing etc etc let's
look at the Northeast so this is where
it's the most expensive and it's almost
double I mean that's crazy if you're in
the Northeast it is almost double and
this is for high-income families now
let's look at the the rural graph let's
see where it's cheap although this
doesn't seem that cheap to me over the
course of 18 years rural families are
spending around one hundred forty five
thousand dollars to raise children by
the way the country's medium income
remains more than eight percent below
where it was before the recession but
child care health care costs are still
going up faster than inflation so all of
this just sort of adds to a lot of
badness economy not great costs going up
by the way we do plenty of stories here
about how college education no longer
gets you the jobs better you seem to
point out that this does not include
college this is for the busy 18 years of
life so we're not even factoring college
cost here yeah uh what was that they
take away mama look I had a baby in 2013
what was I did I not check these faxes
get mailed to me did no one put this in
a class that's not a you don't get like
a packet we they don't give you a
pamphlet and rightly so because people
wouldn't have children reading that they
just say no lock it up I don't want it
it's not fortunately I think those
figures are probably low I think I spent
two hundred forty five thousand dollars
just last week increasing our swimming
class and gymnastics and they don't even
account for like the extras that you
have to do just to keep your child in
the same race you know they have the you
know Spanish class French class now you
need you know
Mandarin I could drop French oh my oh I
took French the last time you spoke
Paris I use a lot but no it's just
overwhelming to think that it's only
going to increase
it doesn't include college where are
people supposed to get this money and
you brought up the rural area being you
know one hundred and forty five thousand
dollars will they make a lot less yeah
so it feels like four hundred thousand
dollars to them until you just don't
know what you're gonna do but we've been
doing it for years
you know these children still get raised
they still grow up they still go well
some of them still go to college and
somehow someway parents make it happen
you cut costs where you can so is that
the overriding theme on this thing like
when I see these studies it's like you
know what people just this is what life
is like you just keep moving forward the
next generation keeps coming and yet
maybe it gets more expensive and more
difficult but like it just kind of keeps
rolling along sure you can argue that I
would say that it keeps getting worse
for some people and it stays the same or
gets better for others and that's that's
a small minority there right um you know
but Vanessa to your point you talked
about these you know extracurricular
activities this like summer school and
things like that and I think because we
see such a huge cost to having a child
those families who have more money are
going to be able to provide those
resources like summer cap to their
children and this is increasing the
education gap and that's one of my
serious concerns when I look at data
like this I know that you know the kids
in upper middle class you know upper
family upper-class families are going to
get that instruction in the three months
they have off whereas other children
might not right so how much of this then
is just keeping up with the Joneses like
that you have to give your kid French
and Spanish and how about something
useful our Spanish it does it a new
school well you know to me like you got
like if everyone else is taking swimming
classes you got to take the swimming
classes and gymnastics and all that I
don't think that's so much it's the part
of keeping up with the Joneses but you
know if I buy a Greco
high chair that's only like 70 bucks and
someone goes and buys this new fancy
Stoker yeah Sheamus two hundred and
fifty dollars back that's where the
disconnect is and that's when you're
trying to keep up with the Joneses I
think it's healthy to put a child into
different activities to kind of flush
out what their interest is interests are
I did
and you can do free activities to what
they exist yeah but you do a lot of
things and by the time you're in high
school you realize what your passion is
you focus on one thing and it doesn't
cost as much money so I don't think so
much of it is keeping up with the
Joneses it depends on your family and we
don't believe in living outside of our
means so if I can't afford it we don't
buy it it's very simple for us you bring
up an interesting point with the like
high chairs or like all this I don't
even know what kind of high I want to
talk about strike oh is that what I want
to talk about that say well we're good
but you know I think a lot of times
parents are placed in a position where
they feel like they have to buy that
other chair because it's safer because
that's the thing that the good parent
would do so it places an unburden
stressed on on these families that don't
have the means to perhaps purchase that
chair but they're gonna put it on their
credit card because that's what a good
parent does and they don't want their
kid to fall and have a concussion but I
also fear has a lot yeah but at one
thing that doesn't cost any money is
research you can research what the
differences are you can research what
tests were done you can research to see
if in fact one is safer than the other
but you have the education to understand
how to think critically be information
available to you and if you have the
time if you're not working two jobs then
yes I would argue you can you can do
that if you have internet in your home
but if you don't have these resources
available you're at it right so it's
such a huge double-edged sword because
we don't fund education properly then
these people feel like they have to send
their kids to private school so then
already they're now putting more money
into that system we're putting less
money to the public education system but
let's talk about these stoker Stokoe cuz
my brother got one for his kid
not a stroller oh but you can't but they
never use it because you get so Smita
Milus that you can't like hang [ __ ] on
it which I guess parents have a lot of
[ __ ] you know me like there's a lot of
bags and like cookies and things and it
looks like a spaceship I almost don't
know how to work it now I will say that
I have to still go carrier but I didn't
pay for it that's for free yeah and it's
like a contraption that I cannot figure
out like you strap the baby and the
baby's like on your back your neck your
head you're flipping it around it's it's
more than
he's not gonna be happy about the motion
you're getting the radio I have a
website that you know I dedicated solely
to mommies and babies and figuring all
this out and you know I'm not play
cating to any brand you know sometimes
the cheaper brands are crap they're [ __ ]
sometimes and sometimes the more Smiths
and Friends are that for a reason but
you don't need a spaceships stroller you
really don't because you can get a
number of stroller and I know I'm going
way too far with but you can get a cheap
shoulder that stroller baby and is not
going to knock it out and give it a
concussion there you go people you don't
need a spaceship stroller what's your
what's your website by the way I
actually went on your website the other
day it's awesome actually
layout is very cool like you learn about
some some motherly things